Speaker 1: Hurricane Ian is bearing down on
the state of Florida after ravaging Cuba.
We've talked about it to some degree.
As of this moment, two and a half million
Floridians are without power.
And we are told that fatalities are in the
hundreds.
The federal government should do what it can
to help Florida.
That is my position.
It has been the case with hurricanes in other
states and tornadoes and whatever else.
I am consistent on that issue.
But many Republicans are not.
We've seen so many Republicans vote against
federal funding for disasters in other states,
but then go and beg the federal government
for help when the disaster is in their state.
That gets us to Florida Republican Governor
Ron DeSantis.
Ron DeSantis, who has been one of the wildest
critics of President Joe Biden, is now all
of a sudden being very nice because he needs
Joe Biden's help.
He needs the federal government's help.
What happened to Florida being a big boy,
patriotic, self-sufficient state who doesn't
need anybody's help and they have all the
freedom in the world?
Well, all of a sudden they're issuing mandatory
evacuation orders, which I agree with, but
they're not exactly the freedom that Ron DeSantis
has touted.
All of a sudden, DeSantis wants federal cash
for disaster relief, even though DeSantis
in 2013 voted no for Superstorm Sandy relief
funding for New York and New Jersey.
Is he a hypocrite?
Of course he is.
But it's been really funny watching him try
to equip a equivocate when being interviewed
by Sean HANNITY on Fox News, which we're going
to get you in a moment.
Newsweek article DeSantis Praises Biden as
Florida Governor Changes Tone Before Hurricane
Ian.
What a surprise.
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis has expressed
gratitude towards President Joe Biden for
his cooperation as Hurricane Ian is due to
hit the state.
Let's take a look at the video clip, which
you will find is the Santos singing a very
different tone about Joe Biden.
Speaker 2: Let's talk about you had a conversation
with the president today earlier in the day.
There had been talk that the president spoke
with mayors, but not you.
But apparently the president reached out to
you tonight.
Can you tell us about that conversation?
And in the aftermath of this storm, what support
Floridians can expect from the federal government?
Well, Sean, you know, what I said today is,
you know, my phone lines open when people's
lives and their property are at risk like
this.
You know, we all need to work together, right?
Speaker 1: When people's lives are at risk,
we need to work together.
Otherwise, I'm going to tell horrible, corrosive
lies.
Speaker 2: Are those the party lines?
The Biden administration has approved our
request for a pre landfall declaration and
did that very quickly.
So so we're thankful for that.
Know obviously as this the impacts are known
you know there's going to be more requests,
particularly for individual assistance for
Floridians that may have been displaced.
You know, and it's my sense that the administration
wants to help.
I think they realize that this is a really
significant storm.
And there's a lot of people that, you know,
we're working with the locals.
We work very well with them, of course, at
the state level.
But we really need everyone working together
to make sure people have their needs tended
to.
Speaker 1: This is about a bunch of different
things, so let's see if we can go through
it.
First of all, is DeSantis a hypocrite on this
issue of federal funding?
Of course he is, and so many Republicans are.
You had members, elected officials from the
Midwest who were begging for money for tornado
recovery, who had voted against money for
New York and New Jersey, for Superstorm Sandy
recovery back in 2013.
And I could go on the list is so long and
the earthquakes the Rand Paul, Kentucky all
these different they're all hypocrites.
Okay.
So that's one layer.
And DeSantis is, of course, a hypocrite.
Second thing.
When DeSantis talks about this is not the
time for pettiness, this is not the time for
political division, etc..
He's agreeing that much of what he does is
simply petty and when it's inconvenient.
Or whether he believes that people's lives
are actually on the line.
He didn't seem to believe it with COVID, but
now with the hurricane, he seems to.
All of a sudden he goes, Now, this isn't the
time for any of that.
Now we're just going to behave like normal
people and we're actually going to work together
because we actually need something here.
So that's the second thing is he's essentially
admitting a lot of his his nonsense is completely
petty and merely political.
But then there's a third aspect, which is
that Ron DeSantis is on the gubernatorial
ballot in, what is it, five weeks, five and
a half weeks or something like that.
He will either be reelected the governor of
Florida, potentially bullying him into running
for president in 2024 or he will lose to Charlie
Crist.
Now, the polling looks fine for DeSantis right
now, for the most part, save one recent poll.
But DeSantis is also acting this way out of
self-preservation because he realizes, much
like Trump's COVID response destroyed Trump's
reelection and much like bad disaster responses
in other states have dramatically impacted
the approval ratings of those leaders.
Think Greg Abbott in Texas.
Although Abbott has now recovered, it's been
long enough he'll probably still win reelection
to governor against Beto in Texas.
DeSantis realizes that the timing of this
hurricane, if there were to be a bad response,
would be really bad for his reelection.
So that's what's happening.
Oh, and then there's a fourth aspect to this
as well, the Trump narcissistic style.
Is extraordinarily transactional.
And so to some degree, this is also DeSantis
thinking to himself.
If I'm nicer to Biden on TV, the federal government
might give us more money.
And of course, Biden knows that this is what
the Santos is doing.
But to praise Biden, quite frankly, Biden
doesn't care.
Biden realizes that it's his job to say yes
when Americans need something.
Americans in Florida need something right
now, so Biden's going to get them the money.
Biden's not perfect.
There's no doubt about it.
But on this, there is a really sharp contrast
between Biden and Trump.
Trump, even in situations of disaster relief,
is extraordinarily petty and narcissistic
and political.
Biden's just going to send the money.
Biden doesn't really care whether Ron DeSantis
is being nice to him on TV or not.
So there's DeSantis all of a sudden saying
No.
I mean, things are going fine with Biden and
we know all the reasons why.
Four different layers as to why this is what's
going on.